are you fired up yet  Pennsylvania packed with presidents this  Tuesday you must vote Republican the  outcome is going to shape our country  for decades to come the high-profile  visits show the Keystone State is key to  who controls the senate for the next two  years  democracy itself is on the ballot the  fact  the race between Democrat John fetterman  and Republican Amendment Oz is one of  the closest in the country that will  bring change to Washington so they treat  us the way we deserve and I'm gonna need  every one of you to go out and have your  plan get your friends get your families  all ready to vote  both fetterman and Oz spent Sunday in  the suburbs around Philadelphia  according key swing voters